be friends
welcome to vcon
[Applause]
I said V friends welcome to vcon
I'm so humbled thank you so much
this weekend is a culmination of many
years of work uh
incredible amounts of focus the last 15
months on this project and I just want
to thank everybody for being here it's
uh it's going to be very special most of
all what I'm most interested in besides
the content is to make sure that as many
of you as possible get to meet as many
of you as possible I think the biggest
Roi from every conference always is the
relationships you make the last seven
years I went to to South by Southwest I
don't think I went to a single talk
it was all just intermingling and
jamming
um that is very clear to me
the thing that you should be looking for
and so I highly encourage extending your
hand and saying hello I know a lot of
people here are naturally introverted
but push yourself this is an incredibly
incredibly kind community
[Applause]
speaking of kindness you know we talk a
good game on kindness on Discord and
social
but people were literally throwing
flying elbows at each other at the merch
tent a few minutes ago
so I want to establish in the opening
Keynote
that please challenge yourself
for the next 96 hours
to being the bigger person in every
situation even if somebody cuts a line
out of their over enthusiasm
or anything else I really really
genuinely
have no interest in hypocrisy within the
framework of this conference so I
challenge everybody to genuinely push
themselves to be their best selves this
weekend please
and by the way just and I really
appreciate that and for the record I'm
really just talking about the last 10
percent ninety percent of the juice here
is off the charts but in excitable
moments I have a selfie station let's
throw up the selfie schedule so that
people can take uh photos because I know
I was out there for four hours please
take a photo of this if you are
interested in getting a selfie I'm
allocating
quite a bit of time to that I'm also
going to ask the uh the thousands
yesterday that were able to get their
photo that if they could be a little bit
patient and let people who were unable
to do that
um and so tonight and tomorrow maybe
please allow that and then we'll see how
Sunday looks
be friends
is
the beginning of a journey for me on the
next chapter of my career
to scale the things that I'm most
passionate about
and those things that I'm passionate
about like for all of us
is in the framework of selfish things
and selfless things
I think the world really struggles with
and
I think that's something for a lot of
you I mean
a lot of you are very close to my
content and know what I talk about what
I believe in
the thing that I've been thinking a lot
about is people's really
people's real struggle with the word and
everything is so or or or
and what I plan on doing with v friends
in the next five decades is really
establish aggressive and
I will build a very large intellectual
property and business
there's probably a substantial chance
that V friends is the business
that finally gets me to buy the New York
Jets
[Applause]
and more importantly win a Super Bowl
I really need everybody to be healthy
because I really need you to be there to
watch when they give me that Lombardi
Trophy
because if you think my face was a meme
in that CNBC interview
wait till you see my Super Bowl trophy
face
but but more importantly
more importantly the selfless journey of
what I think be friends will be and can
be for me
is very important to me I genuinely
believe I mean look how good these
characters look spinning around the
stadium
this is a little ways away from a couple
of Doodles just a year ago
there's literally characters walking
around here we're only 15 months into
this journey
we're going to operate this very
aggressively and we will make these
characters incredibly popular
almost everybody's grandkids in this
place will interact with a v-friend in
their life
and the thing that I'm most passionate
about with that is obviously the
attributes of the V friends
what we can instill
yesterday was one of the great days of
my life four and a half hours of selfies
and conversations
I wish on you besides Health the
opportunity to have one person ever tell
you that you changed their life it's not
about the 500 that did it yesterday one
one person has a better life because of
you that is the most intoxicating
feeling
a human being can have
I love you much more
I have a very scaled vision for this
and I'm very excited to operate it I
want you to all know that I will not let
you down I will navigate every day
I will rarely listen to any of your
opinions
I'm very aware that you care about the
floor price I can't do that I have a
responsibility
but I will navigate this the way I've
navigated everything in my life
with Supreme effort
with a hell of a lot of hard work
with a lot of clever smarts and with
tremendous good intent I make you that
promise and I'm humbled by your support
[Applause]
now let's talk about you
my great hope for this weekend
is what happens to you is what happened
to me when I started to go to
conferences in web 2. I had a lot going
for me
the wine business with dad was going
great I knew a lot
but I started to go to these conferences
and I heard things I'd never heard
before
conversations I've never heard before
and it really changed the course of my
life
the conferences I went to in 2006 and
seven
shaped who I am today
my ambition for vcon over the next three
years is to provide not only the
community that I know is happening
but the information
the one sentence in one talk this
afternoon that makes a click for you of
why you can do this for your law
practice or your concrete business or
maybe it is time to step away from your
job live a little more humbly within
your means and try one time to scratch
that itch that's been inside of you
forever
the content
not just the community of this
conference
has tremendous ambition has a lot of
thought to it The Luminaries and
personalities that are here are
extraordinary there are many artists
that will be speaking at this conference
that only 15 months ago had regular jobs
how many people here by show of hands if
I really ask this question and I want
you to really give a thought don't just
raise your hand how many people if I
asked you this question would say as a
child they did grow up fairly artistic
they drew they played they think they
were creative and because web3 didn't
exist
they didn't know that was an option and
they ended up doing a non-creative thing
in their lives actually please stand up
if you're one of these people please
stand up
let's clap it up for these creative
individuals
don't sit back down
back up thank you
it's these people that really sit in my
gut
because they may think as I'm talking
now darn it nine-year-old me would have
really won if this worked out
I wish I could bring the two guys back
on right now to make the joke of you're
80 you're still young
I look at the faces that just stood up I
just don't think human beings are good
at understanding time
every person that just stood has a
dramatic amount of time to execute their
own V friends
it may not be what V friends ends up
being because let's call a spade a spade
I'm really good at what I do
however
it can be more for them than even be
friends is for me because doing
something you like and living within
those means whatever that number is
whether it's eighty thousand dollars a
year or two hundred thousand dollars a
year is genuinely
genuinely the greatest gift a human can
have besides good health
and so I cheer for these individuals I
hope you get inspired and I hope you
make a jump I really do thank you
[Applause]
perspective
something as I continue to go through my
life that interests me quite a bit is
that life is so binary based on what
you've decided you want to find
the ability to find negativity on an
everyday basis I'm sure this will
confuse no one based on how good the
mainstream media and human beings on
social media are at pushing and selling
negativity the ability to find
negativity on an every hour basis is
extremely easy
the thing that I am far more interested
in
is the ability to find positivity is
there at all times as well
if I had one big massive macro goal for
vcon
if vcon can be the extra juice the extra
little push
to tip some of you over that are on your
journey to deciding to be optimistic
versus defaulting into being pessimistic
if this event and other people's love
towards you
the love that likely if you are that
person you are not given along the way
if this community can do that for each
other if this event can be the container
of that
this would be a remarkable weekend and
so I ask the people
at this conference
that if you were happy and optimistic to
over communicate that to every friend
you make
to step up to your fellow V friend that
might not be there and try to build that
bridge I genuinely believe
that people are really missing the
Simplicity of life
choosing to be optimistic and happy is
hard when you were built to be negative
and cynical
recognizing its truth and putting in the
work no different than doing exercise or
eating better or reading and learning
about web 3
recognizing that truth and putting
yourself on a path to try to go there is
not as difficult
and so I hope that we can choose
practical optimism this weekend and I
encourage it very much
next
I want to give a humongous and I mean
massive shout out
to that dude
let's all look at them one dude over
Polaris sitting let's wave it dude I
love the whole section yeah you brother
you let's [__] go
that dude has a whole [__] section to
himself he's a gangster he's a
one-of-one look at him he's a star let's
[__] God
ha
I love that move
it's a little too introverted for me
but I'm glad let me do this let me do
this I saw it I saw it
my friends
I expect lots of competition at vcon
I want to know everyone's scores in
Candyland I want to see people crying if
they're losing
we must Champion competition the reason
competitive clown is going to be a beast
is be friends is going to eliminate
eighth place trophies
[Applause]
competitive clown is gonna make
seven-year-olds cry
he's a clown he's scary
you know what else is scary coming in
second
I love
people that come in second third fourth
I love losing you know that I really do
the point isn't trying to make kids
unhappy that came in second third fourth
fifths our reaction was eighth place
trophies
that was the wrong move on that the
right move was Champion when you went
all the way and respecting the Merit of
coming in Forth
when we eliminate Merit we get into a
dangerous place
Merit is good competition is good
tenacity is good
ambitious Angels the best
who's got an ambitious angel
I see you brother
I also
am extremely excited for the late nights
after the conference
I expect people communicating where they
are so others can find you I expect
people when they're leaving here if they
see somebody walking solo saying come
with us we are building a real community
and I'm really really genuinely excited
to be a part of it
at the helm of it to be with you
I think that there's an incredible
chapter of web 3 that's coming this next
year
I would argue that unlike some of the
rain we got
the timing of vcon from a web 3
standpoint could have not been better
I've personally and you know this I've
put out a lot of videos a lot of you
I've read the comments didn't love when
I was fudding when I said 98 of projects
are going to zero that wasn't flooding
that was please be careful I've seen
this movie twice before
the timing of this conference
is unbelievably good
everybody here is wildly aware that
there's been correction in pricing that
is the best thing that has happened to
us
this will clean out some of the very
dangerous I would call it behavior that
captures all of us in it
it's not fun when your assets go down on
paper that's not fun I'm sure some of
you are in the stock market too there's
other things coming after that so it is
what it is
but
the timing is remarkable
because now a lot of the good work gets
done
a lot of the real learning gets done
a lot of the Innovation gets done the
next two three years for web 3 will be
remarkable I ask
in the opening Keynote for all of you to
double down on something very important
which is education
I think my message for years has always
been confused because of how angry I get
at college debt
I am not thrilled with the current way
that America and many other countries
sell education
I believe in education more than
anything
it is why we went on a four-month
journey to how to set up a metamask how
to buy ethereum and many in this
audience went through that Journey
and not only one with v friends but one
in many other great communities like
many of you minted board ape many of you
minted world of women many of you did
many other things
right now if you're here you've got a
baseline education
you've got a baseline education
this is when you have to Triple down on
your education
let me give you a really good hypothesis
for this conference
you've probably decided which panels you
want to go with
or considering
many of you are going to choose based on
the person and you think they're cool or
the subject matter is something you
already know and like
please challenge yourself to go to two
three five twenty five fifty percent of
the panels where you know nothing about
it
where you're not sure about it
this is the time to Triple down on
education in web 3.
so much is about to be built in the next
three years
I highly recommend you do that
my friends this is a party
this is a gathering
this is a culmination
of a very strong Community built on very
good values I am uncomfortably proud of
you
I'm incredibly humbled
could we throw up the selfie station
before I get out of here one more time
my main goal I've won kpi for vcon I
wanna
talk to all of you
I want to say hello I want to say thank
you
I want to be the Best Host I can
um
and I just wanna
be with you
and I just thank you so much really from
the bottom of my heart thank you for
being at Becon one I adore you I love
you I can't wait to see you and have the
greatest greatest greatest greatest
greatest greatest
v-con
I see you up in there in the seats let's
[__] go thank you everybody I'll see
you here
[Applause]